President Trump and Russian President
Vladimir Putin have spoken for the first
time since the release of the Muller
report mr. Trump said he and Putin
discussed several matters he says they
briefly talked about the Russia Pro but
mr. Trump said he did not warn Putin not
to meddle in next year's election this
as the democrat-led House Judiciary
Committee has given Attorney General
William Bar a deadline to turn over an
unredacted copy of the Muller report
Steve Dorsey is at the White House with
more Steve good morning Anthony good
morning the call between the two leaders
lasted more than an hour with the
Kremlin signaling mr. Trump and Putin
plan to ramp up dialogue with each other
I had a very good talk with President
Putin following a meeting with Slovakian
Prime Minister Peter Pellegrini in the
Oval Office President Trump
described a warm conversation with
Russian counterpart Vladimir Putin we
talked about many things Venezuela was
one of the topics and he is not looking
at all to get involved in Venezuela but
that's at odds with assessments from his
own administration including Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo who's due to meet
next week with Russian Foreign Minister
Sergey Lavrov at a summit in Finland the
Russians have people working over there
in the hundreds if not more the these
are the folks who are actually
controlling the direction of travel for
Venezuela Pompeyo also says the US won't
rule out military intervention in
Venezuela to aid opposition leader Hwang
Guido it's a move that could threaten to
escalate tensions there with Russia in
his call with Putin the president says
he also indicated he'd be open to an
agreement with Russia and China to
reduce some nuclear firepower the two
also discussed North Korea Ukraine trade
and the Mullah report he actually sort
of smiled when he said something to the
effect that it started off as a mountain
and it ended up being a mouse but he
knew that because he knew there was no
collusion whatsoever but Democrats
aren't smiling on Capitol Hill where
House Judiciary Committee Chairman
Jerrold Nadler issued a new demand
Friday for attorney general bill Barr to
turn
in unredacted Muller report and
underlying materials by Monday at 9:00
a.m. or the committee will move to
contempt proceedings it comes after bar
was a no-show at a house hearing
Thursday after testifying for five hours
to the Senate Judiciary Committee the
day before Democrats accused Barr of
lying to Congress about Robert Muller's
concerns about his initial conclusions
of the report in a Friday letter to
Muller Senate Judiciary Committee
chairman Lindsey Graham asked him if he
felt Barr misrepresented their telephone
conversation and his Senate testimony
this week meanwhile it appears unlikely
the president will allow former White
House lawyer Don McGann to testify to
lawmakers about him disobeying in order
to remove Muller as special counsel
tarika Thank You Steve Dorsey at the
White House